[Musik]
ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen blöd
dass sich die original nicht daneben
habe aber warum auch wenn die welt was
dir doch der rückseite auch designed by
apple in california heute ein guter
anfang
ich bin eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr
darüber reden aber ab und den gala- eine
million sind wir bald ganz kurzen klick
sagt euren freunden erstellt 52
abonniert ihnen genau was knapp und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
sollte ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es
gut
bevor wir loslegen gestern kam der alex
miescher online hat schon gesehen da
gibt's unter anderem diesen jogginganzug
ich habe nämlich auf die hose führen die
habe ich nämlich gar nicht an oder auch
dieser holy den ich als fünf tage bei
meiner reise an orte und deswegen schon
etwas träge geworden ist übrigens viele
haben mich gefragt wofür denn bei diesem
sugar dass er steht oder warum das rot
ist ich schon liebe nämlich auf die idee
gekommen das gut zu machen weil die
anfangsbuchstaben eines vor und
nachnamens sind und wie suzuki weil das
ich fand das war einfach so ein neues
denken so zugang zu einem hauptthema
offen könnte haben sich schon okay doch
dann kommen wir aber jetzt heutigen
video thema du kannst ich war schon mal
hin lassen
ich bin nämlich richtig krank ist und
ich glaube alle leute die jetzt mal
gesagt haben komm osten könne immer nur
noch web videos sind jetzt auch wieder
gespannt weil wir haben heute nicht
irgendwelche airports wir haben airport
pro fakes aus schönsee fans
unwahrscheinlich ich habe die dinger
zugestellt bekommen ich frage euch sehr
gerne in den längen ganz ohne video
beschreibung ich meine die kosten
irgendwas zwischen 35 und 40 euro
als wenn man die jetzt mit den
originalen vergleich für 279 auch schon
getestet habe ich auch sehr gerne
anschaut das ist natürlich schon in
preislicher unterschiedlich meinen wir
legen hier soweit ein siebeneinhalb bis
ungefähr das original preis ist aber die
müssen jetzt natürlich auch was taugen
damit ich zufrieden bin so das ist das
produkt
ich habe hier immer schon einmal zeigen
da fällt mir auf wir haben eine ziemlich
große verpackungen untersteht airports
produziert echt drauf kümmern
das hatten wir noch nie wirklich das
hatten wir noch bei keinem einzigen
produkttester das ist irgendwas airports
credit stadion case erste einigung ist
auf jeden fall ganz gut so gut wenn man
an diese seite betrachtet ist ja einen
ob wieder weniger gut aber es geht ja
nur um die qualität vielleicht sogar
richtig gespannt bin ob sie auch noise
cancelling haben das habe ich nämlich
auch gar nicht nach geschafft vor das
wäre natürlich gut dass wir und wenn das
dann auch noch gut funktioniert das wäre
natürlich klasse
so jetzt müssen die erstmal raus aber
hatten wir dann bei den original kann
manches für fans hatten wir bei den
originalen hatten wir bei den originalen
auch so ein bisschen doch besser mein
gott ich weiß gar nicht ob das legal
nicht du hast es ja erwarten man darf da
werden ja nun nicht herstellen glaube
ich oder weil das ja auch in china zum
beispiel in der 450 euro frei männern
veltheim kommen okay das war ja deutlich
unter den aber dass ich es wirklich
steht designed by apple in das bei jedem
exemplar ist keine ahnung das ist
manchmal so ein mysterium und bei dem
bei den händlern
gut dass gleichheit wirklich gibt ihr
das mal da designed by apple in stellung
sie ist ja wahrscheinlich hinter
stickerinnen ticker alles nachgemacht
außer die sticker akustik eigentlich
dann haben wir das bei den original
alltag und hier sogar die diese in ihr
opfer auch noch dabei also darf sich
jemand aus scheint wirklich mühe geben
an die ist nicht wissen schon sehen ist
die stadt war dort alles herkommt
ich glaube das ist das erste kabel das
ich bekommen immer so aussieht das war
nicht mehr bei den originalen dabei wir
haben ja lightning in usb ich glaube
jetzt besser nicht aber auch echt
interessant okay und jetzt kommen wir zu
dem wichtigsten
eigentlich ja also wie der erste
eindruck ist schon brutal gut ist
natürlich jetzt ein bisschen blöd dass
sich die original nicht daneben habe
aber warum auch wenn die welt das ist
jedoch der rückseite auch designed by
apple in california
aber sonst eine mutter steht will in
china aber trotzdem christus drauf auf
die kamera nicht ganz na gut ich glaube
das ist ja so klein das kann man kaum
lesen ich muss auch sagen hier dieses
magnet case wirklich fühlt sich richtig
gut an
also so gut haben was auch noch nie tja
irgendwie mal ein bisschen schade für
apple das dann so viele nachbarn und
auch die kopfhörer ohne scheiß eins zu
eins gibt ihr das recht haben die recht
große markierungen aus
diese schwarzen diese schwarzen striche
das recht aber nicht mehr unsicher aber
ich meine schon latte macchiato sie
haben wir die originale und dieses
schwarze dingen existiert hat also ich
meine ich hätte mir auch so bleibt das
sieht vielleicht ein ganz kleines
bisschen anders aus okay und hier steht
auch wieder was dran ist steht auch noch
mal ganz klein apple
ok dann würde ich sagen wir ballern
thema ins ohr ich habe jetzt ein kleines
kind schon gehört weist die klicken so
kann manchmal ganz kurz in die
beschreibung schauen die beschreibung
ist glücklicherweise hat auch auf
englisch
ich habe es gerade mal hier die
beschreibung überflogen noise cancelling
habe ich jetzt noch nicht gesehen aber
vielleicht können wir das ja trotzdem
gleich noch aktivieren
auch wenn nicht alle das war schon echt
krass wenn dann wenn das funktioniert
dass er anders trotzdem kollekte jetzt
mal eben mit meinem handy
guck mal die sind halt auch wirklich
direkt mit apples pro deklariert
verbinden taste drücken
das ist schon krass das ging so schnell
ging es glaube ich auch er also schon
also bis jetzt mediensteuerung okay für
wiedergabe anhalten drücke einmal auf
einen der
airports ja das weiß ich geräusch
kontrolle drückte auch ziemlich glaube
ich bei jedem wetter drücke auf den
schieberegler laufsteg und weitere steht
ja wohl die werkschauen ich stecke jetzt
mal ins ohr
vielleicht hat mir auch jemand so
wollten wir streichen hat mir original
reingesteckt hat kann ich jetzt gleich
aber sofort sagen wenn die musik live
kann man meinen wenn ich den auch
dahinter mal ein werden und das
urheberrecht ja wird sofort gesperrt
[Musik]
ich hatte mich leute triffst du deinen
job da kann sich das rein machen das
lied mit recht kann können die das nicht
bei mir runter kannst du das nicht sagen
ja also ich lasse jetzt mal drin kurz
ich muss sagen du kannst natürlich
gleich auch noch keine einschätzung
geben
vom sound her ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen es waren bis jetzt wenn ich jetzt
mit allen die schon getestet hat
abgesehen von original natürlich die
besten die sind besser als die 1000 gehe
ich ja sonst immer so angepriesen habe
sage ich man muss auch sagen die gehen
extrem laut also ich habe mich gar nicht
getraut auf lotte stufe zu stellen weil
das das hätten wir die ohren weg
geballert der bass könnte vielleicht ein
bisschen besser sein also wenn dann wenn
es dann so richtig losgeht im drop das
ist das einzige was ich sagen würde okay
das ist bei den originalen deutlich
besser ansonsten bin ich überzeugt muss
ich sagen du kannst ja auch gern mal
reinhören ich bin mal gespannt was du
sagst du musst deine hände davon weg
nimmt uns die serie ja das spielfeld
eindeutig und bass und sonst sonst finde
ich ok das ding ist ich glaube ich mag
einfach nicht kopfhörer die man sich so
tief in die ohren stecken muss das heißt
ich halte ich bis jetzt immer noch
begeistert muss sagen also für das geld
kann man nicht mehr kann aber das habe
ich ja auch bei den originalen gesagt
also der sensor ist ja wirklich krass da
muss man ganz aufpassen ich aktiviere
die ganze zeit zu mir schauen wir noch
reden also ich habe gerne mal
nachgeschaut und ich glaube ein neues
kennenzulernen ist leider nicht möglich
aber das hätte mich auch gewundert für
den preis trotzdem also gut so ich weiß
nicht wie wir müssen auf jeden fall noch
das mikrofon testen
ansonsten kann man die auch ganz normal
steuern wie alle anderen airport aber
gut das hatten auch schon und noch
andere feld pause weiter nicht das war
ja genau
also das klingt immer so leicht wenn man
irgendein befehl gibt das haben wir bei
den originalen auch nicht aber ist ja
auch nicht so schlimm
markus mikrofon ich habe irgendwie doch
noch ein prozent akku aber ich wusste
ich muss man ja noch ganz anders aus
allerdings gibt es aber trotzdem jetzt
mehrfach dem kollektor jetzt aber hey
was geht verstehst du mich mit großer
schrift wirkt wie ich verstehe hier gut
da wird richtig bearbeitet das hat schon
mal bessere stand ja komm mal her wir
tauschen mal kurz ja richtig gut und du
bist halt sogar von meinem handy welt
also die das ganze augen heißt darf man
noch mal was zum beispiel ich weiß mein
handy ist werde ich ja noch ein prozent
also ich bin schon zufrieden so lassen
sie die privat gern wenn du jetzt nicht
das geld wenn ich nicht also jetzt noch
eine flex modus zurück zur frage also
schön mit den polen so auch wenn ich
sagen muss dass ich das nicht unbedingt
unterstützen wenn man es wirklich so
krank so muss ich sagen trotzdem sind
natürlich die originalen sehr sehr teuer
und da würde ich mir auch wenn ich genug
geld zur verfügung hatte sich mit
trotzdem die man muss sich ja heute die
frage ist jetzt natürlich das eine
exemplar seine sponsoren verlosen mache
ich wirklich weil ich präferiere meine
airports zuerst generation immer noch
weil dies in form sound einfachheit
besser schützen werden die auch in
seinem fall los da heißt ich alles wie
könnt ihr mir sehr gerne folgen und was
ich auch noch sagen muss ich habe noch
viele sachen die jetzt raus geschickt
werden irgendwelche gewinnen weil ich
jetzt in letzter zeit nicht zu hause war
und die meisten sachen bei meinen eltern
rumliegen das tut mir ein bisschen leid
ich aber schon shakes gewissen aber das
postamt in der story wenn ich die
verschicke und so folgt mir sehr gerne
auf instagram aber nicht den kanal dann
haben wir bald die millionen
das war es hart ein
[Musik]